recent protests inside Iran have been
deadly with security forces turning
their weapons on their own people and
threatening to resolutely confront
growing unrest over economic struggles
the regime has also lashed out at the US
and Israel accusing them of trying to
trick protesters today the Israeli prime
minister spoke directly to the Iranian
people on Twitter the Iranian people are
brilliant they're innovative so why is
e1 so poor why is unemployment so
rampant the answer is in tours the
regime US officials have also been quick
to blame Tehran's corruption and
mismanagement for the country's economic
troubles workers aren't getting paid
strikes are a daily occurrence and the
rial is plummeting youth unemployment is
at a staggering 25 percent analysts
suggest the anger isn't solely about
economic concerns the recent protests
including the nationwide bus and truck
drivers strikes are actually designed to
say that politics and economics are
linked in the Islamic Republic and those
who want a better lot in life also want
a better government president Trump's
decision to pull out of the Iran nuclear
deal is giving the regime ammunition to
take a hard line with French energy
company total it has 60 days to
negotiate with the US government to
secure an exemption from American
sanctions otherwise Iran's oil minister
is threatening to give control of the
world's largest gas field to a Chinese
state-owned company this is the Trump
administration is putting the financial
squeeze on Tehran and trying to win over
its people US officials assessed that
the Iranian people particularly the
younger population are eager for
economic political and social change
so all indications are the Trump
administration will not let up